hello this is Mark Lawson for GameSpot
I'm here once again with cam Robinson
Nikki always here wow you're always here
he said this time we are in the halls of
the corner where we just went to visit
square enix
mm-hmm we saw a new game from dontnod
studios who the guys who made remember
me if you remember that so what was the
game we saw we saw it life is strange
which is a new episodic or adventure
game so it's in the sort of sort of in
the same vein as sort of The Walking
Dead games like that telltale games yeah
the telltale stuff so essentially it's
an adventure game but instead of being
based like on very complicated puzzles
is based on character development story
story and this mystery because basically
it takes place in this in this town and
you play this lead character max he
returns from moving a wage comes back to
air time as a teenager and reunited with
her best friend who's changed completely
you know she's I think her dad has died
so she's a really traumatic time so
she's there this rebel but she's also
convinced that her other best friends
has no disappeared and I think it looks
like you're gonna help her try and track
down yeah this missing best but it's
sort of like a sort of maybe a murder
mystery nothing I mean obviously a lot
of these games what's important about
them is the character development the
story and yet typically the voice acting
you know it's gotta be really good and
certainly it's in the early stages this
is so far but you want
I mean we've only seen one scene so you
can't read into a whole game before that
and what I did see I wasn't fully
convinced by the kind of believability
of the dialogue if it felt a little bit
trying hard maybe but then I don't know
I was never a teenage girl so I don't
really know sure but one of the best
things about the game I suppose was the
unique twist that they had which was
the her ability to rewind high and
bright yes and they use this in a bunch
of the sort of simpler puzzles in the
game so one of them was that you went to
the cupboard and you pour that box box
fell down and this big glass sort of
fast you were like oh no and then
Khloe's really upset and then you're
like yeah alright so what do you do
where you read one time
and it lets you choose another option
and that goes through everything so like
some dialogue trees - like interactions
with objects all of them will have
repercussions a long line but if you
don't like what the repercussions of
that choice and just made me one time
and do it well you can see all the
dialogue trees if that's what you think
any actually is you can cuz in these
games normally you make a choice and
then you might wonder good happened over
to the other choice and then you go back
and you replay the game maybe sit to
find that out if you loved the game that
much this game you won't have to because
you can rewind at any point and
basically sample all the different
choices and in chooser for everyone
which in one hand is really quite
interesting but the developers have been
like a yeah feel free to choose another
stuck kind of feels a bit like cheating
to me in a way but it's an interesting
way to do it so of I think it's just a
way to you know a different way of
exploring the game kind of acknowledging
that that's kind of what everyone wants
to do is find out what the options are
and the time mechanic gives you a way of
doing that with some sort of magic cheat
button
absolutely so I mean other details about
this title it looks very cool it sounds
sort of unique cell shaded painted sword
amazing and Dishonored so the soldiers
saying all the textures were hand
painted this is on the same thing so
that's interesting
yeah that's look at the so it's looking
quite pretty other things is coming
pretty much to every platform so we've
got PC Xbox 360 Xbox one ps4 ps3 yeah
and it's episodic so there's going to be
a season pass where you'll be able to
download basically buy all the episodes
at once you'd be able to buy them
individually no pricing hasn't yet but
and they and they haven't got exact
dates or anything but they they say
they'd like to have them like a regular
intervals probably monthly releases
after the initial release point yeah I
mean it's an interesting departure for
the studio hopefully we'll get to see
more of it over the coming months in the
meantime if you want more from games
from just head over to GameSpot